en théorie c'est possible d'instituer
don't run mais dans la pratique
concrètement politiquement à washington
on est loin d'être rendus là je vous
explique pourquoi
d'abord regarder qui contrôlent les deux
chambres au congrès ce sont des
républicains du même parti que dans
l'autre choc
ce sont ces leaders qui peuvent décider
de la marche à suivre
peu importe ce que disent les démocrates
s'il y avait des procédures de
destitution ça commencerait à la chambre
des représentants que dit le président
de la chambre des représentants
paul ryan mais les freins cette semaine
en disant qu'il faut prendre son temps
prendre le temps d'aller au fond des
choses ça veut dire deux choses
spécifiquement pour paul ryan
oui il veut entendre james comme et
l'ancien directeur du fbi à savoir si
c'est vrai que donald trump lui a
demandé d'arrêter certaines enquêtes et
pour loyer ne veux pas qu'on oublie
autre chose
la plupart des révélations qui
bouleverse la maison blanche
ce sont des révélations qui viennent de
sources anonymes selon bien des
républicains ces sources ont un agenda
caché
elle souhaite nuire au président
américain il n'y a pas que les élus
républicains qui pense à beaucoup
d'américains le pense aussi
en fait dans notre shop et bien
impopulaire reste qu'il a l'appui de
quatre américains sur dix et ce depuis
bien longtemps
ce qui fait que les élus républicains
demeurent derrière leur président
notamment parce qu'ils pensent à leur
réélection
c'est peut-être pour ça que les leaders
des deux chambres au congrès cette
semaine avec un message il tente de
démontrer que les élus sont au travail
pour ryan l'a dit on veut faire adopter
des lois a adopté des réformes
c'est sur ce qu'on est capable de faire
qu'on sera jugée aux prochaines
élections
[Musique]